and any big and we must do it big F love
find common ground to hold the spread of
lives America First America First non
fatal a website designed for the
explicit purpose of sexually exploiting
children there are fewer evils greater
on Earth than the abuse and exploitation
of innocent children
what you're about to see here is nothing
short of truly disturbing you can never
unknown but we think you need to know
because it's the
truth so let's ditch politics here for a
second
okay everyone loves to talk about common
ground all right let me throw this one
at you here if we don't agree on the
following statement there can never be
hope of finding common ground there are
fewer evils greater on Earth than the
abuse and exploitation of innocent
children I can't think of anything can
you now the worst part of that is that
it happens all the time even worse than
that and what we're about to show you
today with receipts is that often the
perpetrators of this greatest of evils
can be some of the most powerful and
well-connected figures in the world now
if there's one bright spot here it's
that people are are now willing to talk
about it to expose it uh you've seen
this from the you know Epstein story
captivating The public's attention uh
all the way to the shocking I should say
surprising success of 2023 sound of
freedom but you come back to the same
problem how can you separate fact from
fiction conspiracy versus provable
reality and more importantly what can
you do about it and that's what today is
about what you're about to see is the
result of pouring through countless
hours of data analysis through extensive
background verification due diligence
exhaustive research with double triple
checking our investigative unit here mug
Club
undercover was able to connect a
highlevel executive at one of the
world's most powerful entities to a
website designed for the explicit
purpose of sexually exploiting
children now the evil includes but is
not limited to the production
distribution of child pornography and
the
facilitation of sex with children
themselves does that sound too crazy to
be true then you haven't been paying
attention so it's a good thing that we
have the receipts now I want to let you
know this isn't a trigger
warning this is just a warning
what you're about to see he read is
nothing short of truly disturbing the
kind of thing that you can never unsee
you can never
unknow but we think you need to
know because it's the
truth there's been a a tip that has
Associated her with a a rapy website
yeah and what is the newsworthy angle of
wor It's hero1 121 mail.com okay that is
not her email address it has never been
her email address the allegation that
that is any way associated with her is
absolutely false I telling
you the allegation that my client has
anything to do with a child exploitation
or re. XU is false and defamatory and I
am advising you in the strongest
possible terms not
to publish such a
thing on May 11th 2023 the Department of
Justice issued a press release regarding
four men who were sentenced for engaging
in a child exploitation Enterprise the
child exploitation Enterprise being
rape. an open web platform operated by
the late convicted felon Nathan lson
members of this website would share
media of pedophilia child rape and even
tried to arrange in-person meetups
Nathan Larsson died in jail back in
October of 2022 and with the doj's
subsequent sentencing of multiple
individuals for their activity on the
website it is clear efforts are underway
to bring the users of this website to
Justice now it can be difficult for good
people to imagine the kind of evil these
forums and communities attract one
egregious example of the kinds of
criminal activity taking place on the
website was revealed in the probable
cause affidavit for the arrest of then
22-year-old rapy user Ashley Koff the
affidavit describes in disturbing detail
images produced and shared by Koff these
were images of an infant girl posed
being touched and violated in a sexual
manner the summary of evidence against
Koff led to a raid on her home where she
was found with the infant from the
photographs and the infant's father Koff
currently faces the mandatory minimum of
15 years in prison for the production of
child pornography in 2023 cyber security
professional Ryan Montgomery went public
and discussed how he obtained us data
from Nathan larsson's Network in this
case rapy dosu a website constantly on
the Move having switch domains from
rape. to rap.to and so on the data
obtained by Montgomery revealed over
7,000 email addresses of individuals who
became members of rape. suu it's
important to note that the application
process contained questions such as if a
man wants to rape his 3-year-old
daughter up every hole while she's
crying and screaming do you have a
problem with that to be clear the the
only way for these thousands of users to
have their email show up in the database
they or someone who breached their email
account had to answer this question once
on the Forum users posted child sexual
abuse material moderators chimed in and
made it clear users must share their own
child pornography in a direct message
with a moderator in order to access
private sections of their site as well
as to receive an invitation to their
private telegram Channel within the data
obtained by Ryan Montgomery we found a
user account created with the email
address
h121 mail.com connected to the username
Jackie 222 it is worth noting that when
investigating email addresses they often
connect to multiple individuals however
this email address repeatedly linked
back to the one name more than 10
identity verification Services strongly
suggest that this email is only
associated with one possible name Black
Rock managing director Abigail gold
Geller according to an article in the
New York Times from November 15th 2015
team titled Abigail gold Eric Geller
Abigail gold and Eric Geller were
married that Saturday evening on
November 14th 2015 at the Pierre Hotel
in New York the article States Abigail's
Father James Gold retired as a partner
in the managing director for mergers and
Acquisitions at Lazard the Investment
Bank in New York and according to his
LinkedIn he was a senior adviser for SAA
Partners an investment Bank in New York
until 2020 Abigail's husband Eric Geller
is a senior vice president of Jeff an
investment Bank in New York and since
2018 has become managing director of
Jeff he was previously a vice president
of City group from 2007 to
2012 Abigail's father-in-law is Jeffrey
Geller who has been a managing director
of the asset management branch of JP
Morgan Chase in New York for the past 18
years the same JP Morgan Jace that had
to pay $290 million to Jeffrey Epstein's
victims after they continued to do
business business with the convicted
pedophile to be clear there is no direct
connection between Abigail gold Geller's
prestigious family and the data obtained
by hacker Ryan Montgomery idic core.com
has a single result when typing the
email hero1 121 mail.com into their
reverse email search that one result is
an Abigail G Geller idic core.com also
states that the email has been valid
since June 6th of
2018 instantcheckmate.com also states
that hero 121 mail.com allegedly belongs
to an Abigail Geller and also states
that the email has been valid since June
6th of
2018 that's them.com states that hero1
121 mail.com belongs to an Abigail gold
and states it was last updated 4 years
ago a background report on Abigail
Geller obtained on truthfinder.com lists
h121 mail.com as a possible email of
hers as well Ben verified.com states
that hero1 121 mail.com only has one
potential owner that potential owner
allegedly being Abigail gold Geller and
that the email has apparently been valid
since June 6th 2018 when Abigail gold
Geller is searched on white pages.com
hero1 121 mail.com comes up as one of
her emails on check people.com when
searching Abigail gold hero1 121
mail.com pops up again spok.com also
states that hero1 121 mail.com belongs
to an abigailes gold and that the email
was found in one data source 5 years ago
which is unusual given on that's
them.com you can click the tab which
reads run background search and that
directs you to spoko website yet as
previously stated that's them.com says
last updated 4 years ago and spoko says
it was connected to an Abigail as far
back as 5 years ago socialcatfish.com
also States hero1 121 mail.com belongs
to an Abigail gold which also States has
been valid since June 6 2018 and last
confirmed the same day and intelius.com
also links hero1 121 mail.com to an
Abigail gold Geller however this is the
only background report which states the
email was valid since October 3rd 2010
to further corroborate our research we
decided to work with a private
investigator to see if they would come
up with a different conclusion using
Delo a program that licensed private
investigators use for their
investigations our private investigator
obtained this comprehensive report which
contains a wealth of information
regarding an Abigail s gold which
appears corroborated by these other
background checks including the fact
that hero1 121 mail.com was allegedly an
email of Abigail gold this private
investigator was even able to take it a
step further using Delo showing the
addresses the email was used at from
these findings it shows hero1 121
mail.com was used two separate times by
a person named Abigail gold as well as
gold Abigail at a property she owns in
New York City lending more credibility
that this could be AB ga's email and she
was the one using it unfortunately the
report does not indicate when she used
this email and for what purpose to recap
four of these background checks say
hero1 121 mail.com has been valid since
June 6th 2018 one of these background
check says 4 years ago and another says
it was sourced 5 years ago and another
background check indicates it was valid
since October of
2010 however what all 11 of these
background checks strongly suggest is
hero12 1@ mail.com does in fact belong
to an Abigail gold Geller the
inconsistencies in the information seem
to indicate that these identity
verification Services Source their data
from different data providers however we
do not know that for a fact so we
reached out to brief Hernandez of social
catfish investigations to see if she
would come up with a different
conclusion by sending her just the email
hero1 121 mail.com she sent back a
report indicating the email does belong
to an Abigail gold Geller on June 26
2023 hero1 121 mail.com was deactivated
a very easy thing to do on mail.com it's
also important to note that the email
was still deactivated as of September
13th
2023 despite the overwhelming evidence
that this email hero1 121 mail.com which
was found in the database of users from
rape. does belong to a person named
Abigail giler or Abigail gold Geller we
still wanted to provide the opportunity
to Abigail to explain herself and
address address these allegations given
their severity and it very well could
have been someone else using her
email hello hi
Abby it's again do you did you read my
text no what um tell me I'm sorry I'm
just in the what's your name what I'm
I'm an investigative journalist and I
have this tip that uh is claiming that
your emails associated with this rapy
website am I'm just trying to figure out
like what if this is bogus tip or um I
you're you're a journalist from where
mug Club
undercover what is it mug Club
undercover I run the tip line and I it's
just my job to go through and like
figure out what's misinformation or
bogus tips um I just didn't I wanted to
like let you know if there's these
claims going out again around you I
didn't know if you're aware if anybody's
reached out to you if if it's uh valid
or not I I it's not uncommon for you
know things like the emails to get mixed
up
so what's your last name I'm
sorry can I give you a call right back
is this your direct
line yeah that's yeah it is yes it is um
I mean we could I'm just trying to
figure out if this is a valid um tip or
if if this is something that if it's
real or if you're aware of it at all
I'll call you right back okay can I call
you right back yeah sure one would think
an innocent person would be very alarmed
by being identified in this manner and
wonder how their email address was found
on a website such as rape. Abigail
Geller's lawyer Jack Balman founder and
managing partner of jfb legal had this
to say regarding the allegations I
understand that you've asked certain
questions about uh certain allegations
those allegations are false they can be
proven false I'm telling you you should
not publish any such allegations they
are false they are defamatory I was
expecting her to call me back she said
she was going to call me back you know I
was just trying to give her a heads up
um but I mean it's just kind of alarming
for a journalist to get a call I don't
normally get a call from an attorney
right away it's a little weird can you
see where I'm coming
from well I mean
not really when you're things like this
which are very very defamatory and so
you know I'm just representing the CL so
um there's been a a tip that has uh
Associated her with a um a rapy
website yeah and what is the newsworthy
angle with any individual who became a
member of this website is worthy of in
investigation especially a managing
director of one of the largest financial
firms in history it is our contention
that identifying people who join this
website especially those with the intent
to harm children is a newsworthy story
are you familiar with the site
Sir with th let me be very clear M
Geller is not involved in rape she is
not involved in any improper sexual
activity and any allegation that she is
is false and defamatory and will be
taken extremely seriously okay it can't
be clear help me understand this so if
her email was associated with the site
how how how can you prove that she's not
been associated with it I can I will
there is an explan I can explain it and
I will explain it in writing when you
give me your email address as you have
promised to do please give it sure I I
look forward to the explanation why her
email is associated with that site
following these phone calls Jack Balman
sent us a letter stating the following
as can easily be verified online email
addresses supposedly associated with
pornography websites are frequently
falsely linked to numerous different
individuals this statement is irrelevant
as no individuals other than Abigail
gold Geller appeared to be associated in
any of the identity verification
Services indeed you are the second news
organization to receive this malicious
defamatory tip when presented with Miss
Geller's unequivocal denial the first
organization immediately dropped the
story I demand that you and any
organizations you are associated with do
the
same so this is not the first time these
allegations have been brought to
Abigail's and Bowman's attention he goes
on to reiterate it would grievously
misrepresent miss Geller to associate
her with a rape website or anything
similar this statement is unusual as he
claims the information is false but
doesn't acknowledge the name of the
website so either he knows but refuses
to address it or he doesn't know thus
showing he doesn't know whether or not
the information is false as a private
individual Miss Geller is entitled to
the full protection of New York law
including in particular defamation law
any statement asserting or implying that
she is associated with rape pornography
or sexual misconduct would cause her and
her family immense personal and
professional injury and emotional
distress any such publication would
amount to malicious and intentional
defamation and constitute a grossly
irresponsible violation of standards of
information Gathering and dissemination
it would also expose you and any other
individual or organization involved to
liability for compensatory and punitive
damages and other relief while this
letter denies the allegations it
provides no explanation as to how or why
this information is false and threatens
to sue if the information is published
we felt this explanation wasn't
satisfactory so we decided to call him
back the following day it's hero1 121
mail.com okay that is not her email
address it has never been her email
address the allegation that that is any
way associated with her is absolutely
full now I just help me out here how can
you say that's clearly not her email
address though how do you know that you
just found out what the email address is
right you could go register for that
email address today on mail.com it is
not her email address lot of these
research sites so that's what's
confirming this information right and
it's coming on a lot of different
websites so that's what it to you know
us to follow up all we're doing is
asking some questions so you don't even
have the information you're giving me
answers to things and things just aren't
lighting up right now you know I telling
you the allegation that my client has
anything to do with a child exploitation
or rapy doxu is false and defamatory and
I am advising you in the strongest
possible term
not
to publish such a thing okay f i I do
understand you're telling me it's false
but you haven't provided me any
information as to why it's false and
what you if you had done basic diligence
sir what you would know is those
websites are inaccurate indeed many of
them say that they're inac this is a
private citizen she has no public
Persona this this is extremely Reckless
send me the information that you that's
that's part of the problem though Jack
is private citizens are on this website
exploiting
children yeah that's a problem right and
I don't care I don't care who she works
for I don't care I see that's part of
this this here what I what I care about
who does she who does she work for you
know she works for Black Rock yeah yeah
okay so but that irrelevant to what
you're doing uh it doesn't matter where
you work it matters what you do she's on
a child exploitation website doing the
things that happen on that website which
I have seen it's a prop so you know I'm
not threatening anybody I'm doing my job
as a journalist you know and that's it
really listen to me you keep saying she
is doing it is not her can I be any more
clear if you allege that it is her you
will be sued following this phone call
Balman sent an additional email to us
stating the following you claim to have
documentation supporting scarless
allegations against my client Abigail
Geller we have now twice demanded in my
letter last night and in our call that
you provide us with copies of all your
documentation but nothing has been
forthcoming the only supposed
substantiation for these allegations you
have identified are one an email address
called hero1 121 mail.com is associated
with the website rap XU which you
described as containing child
exploitative material two unnamed
sources and unspecified documentation
somehow link Miss Geller to hero1 121
mail.com email
address here Balman doesn't even get the
name of the website correct and it's a
matter of fact that the real website
rapy dosu did contain child exploitative
material he goes on Miss Geller
unequivocally and in the strongest
possible terms denies one ever being
associated with hero1 121 mail.com email
address two ever having anything to do
with rapy doxu website and three any
involvement in any form of child
exploitation you stated in our
conversation that the hero1 121 mail.com
email address is currently unassigned
which itself calls into serious question
the allegations against Miss skeller we
have now learned that the email has been
assigned to the name of an individual
who has nothing to do with Miss skeller
and furthermore that there are at least
two dozen other individuals who have
been separately linked with that email
that completely disproves the anonymous
allegations you have
received there's a lot to unpack here
for starters the identity verification
service we previously cited linked hero1
121 mail.com only to a person named
Abigail Geller the only reason this
email has been made known is because it
was found on rape. which he still can't
get correct amazingly another person
suddenly owns this very obscure email
immediately following the phone call we
had with Balman you could go register
for that email address today on mail.com
it is not her email address the chances
of that happening randomly are
astronomically unlikely lastly there are
not at least two dozen other individuals
who have been separately linked with
that email every single background check
points to this email belonging to a
person named Abigail gold or Abigail
gold Geller unless he knows something we
don't this is a false statement as you
surely know services such as scope now
and accurate warn users not to rely on
any data that is not independently
verified for example acurate States the
public records and commercially
available data sources used on reports
have errors data is sometimes entered
poorly processed incorrectly and
generally not free from defects this
system should not be relied upon as
definitively accurate before relying on
any data this system supplies it should
be independently verified in addition
information from websites like rape. XU
that do not verify emails is itself
untrustworthy it is true that all these
verification Services aren't always 100%
accurate however based on the project
veritos release with one of the
individuals from the website Who
admitted to using it often enough these
verification services are accurate and
given the fact that Balman ordered them
not to publish anything it's safe to say
they met Abigail the same way they met
the man from that initial release
although he continues to get the name of
the website wrong the rapy websites
whether it be
co.to
orsu all verified the user's emails as
provided by an individual who claims to
have investigated this website while it
was
live let me be as clear as possible any
allegation that Miss Geller is
associated with hero 121 mail.com with
rape. XU or involved in any way with
child exploitation is false and liess
given Miss gall's explicit rejection of
these allegations your failure to
substantiate these claims let alone
provide documentation the anonymity of
your supposed Source the information we
have provided and the unquestionable
fact that open source information
linking email to individuals is
unreliable any such publication would be
an intentional and malicious falsehood
subjecting you and any person or
organization acting in concert with you
to compensatory and punitive damages and
other sanctions if you proceed we will
pursue all available legal remedies
against those individuals and entities I
reiterate the demand in my letter that
you immediately provide the supposed
documentation or other material you
claim to have supporting any allegations
against Miss Geller and that you your
organization and its personnel Reserve
all documents relating to her in any way
Balman continues to threaten us with
litigation and relentlessly States how
the allegations are false 11 background
checks which contain a ton of additional
accurate information including other
emails the phone number used to call her
in the first place and addresses all
show this email belongs to her so why
would all of that information be right
but hero1 121 mail.com is not correct as
previously shown it consistently comes
up as belonging to a person named
Abigail gold Geller if these allegations
were as false as Balman claims them to
be why would Abigail refuse to
acknowledge the email why would Balman
claim the information is false yet
consistently spell the name of the
website we found the email on
incorrectly and even more concerning who
signed up for this very specific email
address on this obscure email service
provider following the end of the phone
call on the morning of September 28th
2023 before Balman sent the letter to us
that same evening Bowman himself
admitted that you can go on today and
sign up for that email address you could
go register for that email address today
on mail.com it is not her email address
that same day an individual not
associated with Abigail registered hero1
121 mail.com if you check these identity
verification services today there are
not two dozen individuals associated
with h121 mail.com only an Abigail gold
Geller how in the span of a couple coup
of hours do they know the name of the
individual who clearly just signed up
for the website and has nothing to do
with Abigail or this issue at hand
clearly Abigail and her lawyer Jack
Balman vehemently denied that this email
belongs to Abigail so we cannot
definitively say that it belongs to her
however her lack of concern when the
allegations were brought up Balman
continuously labeling our information
false without seeing it Bowman's efforts
to make excuses with lies including
dozens of other people Associated and
how quickly they knew that new
individual had registered the email
hours after Balman learned what the
email is doesn't make them look very
innocent our team has since reached out
to the Department of Justice's eastern
district in Virginia the same office
that sentenced the four men for engaging
in the child exploitation entprise
rape. we provided both the username
Jackie 222 and the email hero1 121
mail.com to better assist their ongoing
investigation the data provided to us is
limited in scope because of the nature
of the material that was sh shared on
the website for that same reason the
archives that are available online are
also very limited so we hope that the
resources that the doj has at their
disposal will help us better understand
what the account Jackie 222 was doing on
the website and if it was in fact
Abigail
Geller but what do you think is Abigail
gold Geller Black Rock executive
responsible for hero1 121 mail.com
ending up on
rape. or was she the victim of some sort
of misunderstanding that caused the
email to end up on the website it's
possible but here's the
thing you shouldn't have to
answer the people who are paid to find
these answers by your tax dollars have
no interest in finding the answers our
investigative unit reached out to the
doj presented some of our findings in
its response the doj acknowledged our
email but has not followed through with
any investigation of its own but the
double
standard is what's not fine other former
active members of this website are
sitting in jail right now including the
founder of the site by the way who died
in jail because the doj knows that this
is a serious problem so why is Miss
Geller exempt from at least the same
line of questioning let alone
consequences and I think you know the
answer you know when people talk about
we hear this term the swamp or the
establishment you often think of elected
officials maybe your local
representative or Senators uh
Congressman woman
Z's people in positions of power who've
been elected who maybe are greasing some
palms and doing favors for other elected
officials but the swamp goes far beyond
that it includes people who are paid by
your tax dollars who have never been
voted into any position of authority
it's been granted to them and these same
people owe favors to those who do the
granting to the point that it becomes an
incestuous relationship that is
completely in congruent with the best
interests of the people of serving you
the people of getting the truth to you
the people because it's often
uncomfortable it does come down to you
versus
them sometimes now the rapy community
has survived uh several domain posting
changes from the co to the to to the Su
even after the doj shut down the latest
Su iteration of the site the community
is very likely right now still active
and they've just moved on to an unknown
domain something I want to note
everybody else passed on this
story we haven't there's a very strong
likelihood that we get sued for putting
the story out in the public um we
understand this m undercover units
understands
this but we're not going to stop and
we're only able to do this to be clear
because of your support for mug Club
none of this happens without your
support we are entirely funded by
viewers like you we don't say that like
PBS and then collect tax
dollars and it doesn't make business
sense without you this information never
comes to light also if you work inside a
government agency or if you work inside
a place like Black Rock and you are
willing to blow the whistle we
here at louder with Crowder and our mug
Club undercover investigative journalism
unit not only will work with you not
only want to help you we are willing to
go to jail to protect you as a
source